Hey Thoughty2 here.
How many friends do you have?
If the answer is one or two, or even none
at all, then you could be an extraordinary
intelligent person, possibly even genius level.
Either that or you’re a massive gentleman’s
pickle.
Psychologist Satoshi Kanazawa of the London
School of Economics measured the happiness
levels of 15,000 people with various IQ levels.
He measured the happiness of all the subjects
on two occasions, once whilst they were socialising
with a group of friends and then again when
they were completely alone.
What the results showed was that for people
with low to average intelligence levels they
reported greater self-happiness when they
spent time with friends and it seems the more
friends they had, the happier it made them.
But astonishingly, the exact opposite was
true for people with very high intelligence
levels – they reported greater happiness
when alone.
In fact it was noted that those at the top
end of the intelligence spectrum actually
felt considerably less happy when spending
time with friends.
Some theorise this is because intelligent
individuals are more sceptical of others,
they are more-able to see the faults inherent
in humankind and so prefer not to get tangled
up in the blues of their unpredictable and
unreliable brethren.
It’s also thought that when intelligent
people do form friendships, it’s mostly
for personal gain or simply out of awkwardness
and/or expectancy.
Whereas most other people form friendships
for emotional support or a lust for attention
and popularity.
Smart people don’t need emotional support;
we have text books to cry into.
This aversion towards human interaction actually
intensifies in a predictable and linear manner
with increased intelligence.
In the most prime examples of mental acuity
that we’ve come to know and learn about
in school, we see a great struggle to form
bonds and relationships with other humans.
Nikola Tesla never married or had sex, his
tastes were far more avian in nature – he
fell in love with a pigeon…
I shit you not.
He grew a great fondness for one particular
pigeon and actually wrote this about her “I
loved that pigeon as a man loves a woman,
and she loved me.
As long as I had her, there was a purpose
to my life.”
…That’s a bit weird mate.
Brian May lookalike and physicist Isaac Newton
was one of the most brilliant men to ever
walk the Earth.
Seriously we owe a lot to him, he founded
gravity, calculus and the laws of motion,
not to mention countless others – he basically
created the groundwork for all modern-day
physics.
Yet, to say he was socially-awkward is a gross
understatement.
He was immensely private, never formed any
kind of friendship, apart from a mild acquaintanceship
with a Swiss mathematician and he died a virgin.
“Happiness in intelligent people is the
rarest thing I know” – Earnest Hemingway;
and he met a LOT of people.
It’s not that highly intelligent people
are anti-social it’s just that they are
in the vast minority and so struggle to find
others that share their views on the world,
and accept them for all their faults and often
acutely-fastidious nature.
Because after all, no matter how many times
you’ve been told the scientifically-proven
falsehood of “opposites attract”, it’s
similarities that bring people together and
form lasting bonds.
And I guess similarities with others are scarce
when you are adamant that the Earth revolves
around the Sun and the rest of the moronic
folk you share the planet with point-blankly
refuse to believe you.
I know Copernicus, it’s tough, but hang
in there, they’ll believe you, eventually
– just not in your lifetime.
Kanazawa’s study also found a disturbing
correlation that affects all of us, not just
the geeks.
His findings showed that people who lived
in more densely populated areas were significantly
less happy than those in less populated areas.
This is not the first scientific study to
acknowledge this phenomenon.
Countless studies have found that big cities
harbour hatred towards our fellow people.
Whereas the friendliest and most inviting
of people can be found in small towns and
rural settlements.
This phenomenon has been observed all over
the world.
Heck you don’t even need studies to observe
this – just try making eye contact with
literally anybody in London, or just being
a person in Paris – people can be frosty
at the best of times.
Even in these world-class cities that supposedly
provide everything a person could ever want
and more.
Does this reveal a dark truth about the human
condition?
Perhaps we’re not designed to live together
with one-another, no matter how intelligent
you may be.
But that’s not it, because studies show
that friendliness and compassion thrive in
very small communities.
It actually goes back to our evolutionary
past.
Our ancestors living on the great planes of
Africa would have lived in small groups, it
was just more practical this way – easier
to travel and safer when you know everyone
around you by grunt.
Groups rarely mixed and if they did it would
probably end up in conflict, so people just
stayed in their small communities, hundreds
of miles from each other.
And that same attitude is still instilled
deep within us today, as much as some people
feel like moving to a big city and forming
an enormous circle of friends will bring them
success and happiness, we are just fighting
against our own evolution.
Perhaps we should all learn to get along with
the people we know first.
Unless you’re highly intelligent, in which
case, I’m sorry but you’re just not cut-out
for relationships, maybe try befriending pigeon,
who knows, it could even lead to more.
Thanks for watching.